dans leur maison proche de l'église de
fatima à bangui fanni se fait aider par
son compagnon pour se déplacer la jeune
femme a perdu son oeil gauche il y a
deux ans dans l' attaque meurtrière de
son église perpétré par une milice
musulmane du quartier du pk5 l'attaquent
avaient alors coûté la vie à 16
personnes et fait une centaine de
blessés
on était à l'église pendant que l'église
et les bas du sens monter en haut et
j'ai su qu'on évalue son manteau je ne
fus pour aller devant le thème et c'est
là que les grenades ce qu'a eu sur
mesure fanny sait qu'elle ne pourra plus
jamais retrouvé les âges de son oeil
mais elle se bat aujourd'hui pour se
rendre en afrique du nord afin de se
faire extraire un éclat de grenade
toujours présent dans son oeil
les docteurs avaient dit que mes yeux
sont déjà fritschi et je sais pas je
suis là toujours à la maison je souffre
toujours quand il était hospitalisé
j'ai un peu plus des démarches j'ai
commencé d'abord par écrire au niveau de
la cheville et j'ai écrit à l'archevêque
pour demander l'aide de l'église pour
permettre à l'église des mets des
arrivées aucunement femmes à extraire ce
qui est en son nez le cardinal dieudonné
a pas la liga chef de l'église
catholique en centrafrique a promis de
tout faire pour aider progressivement
les victimes de l' attaque à accéder aux
soins adaptés à leur situation
mais sort mais aussi à la responsabilité
des autorités concernant la victime nous
mêmes on s'était engagé comme père parce
que l'église est une mer aussi à la
pendre en charge nos fidèles qui ont un
accueil on perd deux perdu le les yeux
et nous on est nous les accompagnons et
ceux qui sont blessés
nous ne soyons une manière de dire que
nous sommes proches et non un différend
une victime et les victimes aussi
attendent pour entendre
qu'est ce que le gouvernement l'état
injustice fait aussi pour toutes ces
personnes
si le gouvernement avait annoncé au
lendemain de cette tragédie tout mettre
en oeuvre pour que justice soit faite
aujourd'hui la communauté religieuse et
les proches des victimes ignore toujours
où en sont le dossier les enquêtes
judiciaires à l'église de fatima les
cultes ont repris mais les cicatrices
sont là depuis le drame
des militaires sont régulièrement postés
à l'entrée de l'église lorsque des
fidèles sont là pour prévenir toute
velléité